[Music]
foreign
you knew it was me
liaison is a very exciting spy Thriller
mixed with an impossible love story
backbone of the whole series isn't the
romance between evergreen's character
and my character
is set against a background of Espionage
based on real cyber security problems
that can happen and has happened
the whole country is under a massive
Cyber attack so it's quite scary they
can bring this entire city to its needs
and there's nothing we can do to stop
them
Alison lives with Albert
at the start of the story we see them in
love passionate until Gabriel Alison's
ex-lover he resurfaces in Alison's life
unexpectedly and then her whole world is
turned upside down why didn't you ever
tell me about him
cause I'm not
too good she discovers that he's kind of
connected to the cyber attacks so it's
very conflicted she said
I Evergreen were really strong reason
that I wanted to get involved in this
both actors bring a lot of power and
eroticism and intelligence to everything
they do
being on set with her I have to say that
is really easy because she has great
sense of humor he's full of energy he's
very free and crazy in a wonderful way
[Applause]
truck here we go
there's a huge amount of suspense
there's a whodunit of a story to uncover
there's a lot of action sequences in it
it's extremely ambitious I haven't seen
this on television before oh um liaison
is very intense very dramatic pretty
fast-paced it's exciting and it makes
you feel like when you watch it
so it's amazing
foreign